Game of Thrones is one of the bloodiest
shows on television and it takes some
serious creative liberties with the
source material especially since it's
now surpassed the timeline in George RR
Martin's books with a body con that
continues to climb with every episode
never been quite a few characters to
bite the dust on the show even if
they're still alive and well in Martin's
world here are some of those Dead Game
of Thrones characters you may still read
about in the winds of winter Catelyn
Stark on the show Catelyn Stark sad tale
ended when her throat was slipped by the
phrase at the red wedding in the books
though she's still kicking around
although we're not sure you could call
her alive instead of letting Catelyn
rest in peace after she was brutally
murdered george RR martin had the phrase
throw her body into the green Fork of
the trident she drifted downstream until
being discovered by the direwolf Nymeria
it was being unconsciously walked into
by aiya Stark my myriapod Catelyn from
the river and she was later found by
beric Dondarrion and the Brotherhood
without banners
after Thoris of Mia refused to revive
her because she was three days dead
berrak gave Catelyn the kiss of life
himself bringing her back at the cost of
his own life undead Catelyn became Lady
Stoneheart the new leader of the
Brotherhood who set forth on a bloody
campaign of vengeance against anyone
even remotely associated with the phrase
the Bolton's or the Lannisters
although Game of Thrones hasn't been shy
about reviving people from the dead even
ones that were already starting to rot
like the mountain Lady Stoneheart has
never got him to come out to play and
slay on the show Ramsay Bolton Game of
Thrones fans may have breathed a sigh of
relief when the king of cruel finally
bit the dust in season 6 Ramsay Bolton's
death finally gave Sansa Stark some
satisfactory revenge and served up some
payback for all the times had synched
his dogs on other people in the books
though Ramsay is still alive and
wreaking havoc on Westeros right
alongside his dad routes Ramsay lusts
appeared in a dance with dragons after
wedding son says friend Jane poor as
stewards daughter that Littlefinger
trained to impersonate eyre several
weeks after the nuptials are still alive
Mance Rayder disguised himself as a bud
to help Theon and Jane flee Winterfell
before they run into Stannis Baratheon's
army later Jon Snow who didn't know runs
his bride wasn't the real Arya received
a letter from Ramsay
demanding the return of his wife and
reek Ramsey claimed to have defeated
Stannis's army and slain Stannis himself
since we know how much Ramsay loves to
lie I grew up on salt cliff my lord I
was only a boy when they took you away
it would be smart to take the bastard of
Bolton's words with a grain of salt
until we learn the truth in book six
which means we should probably consider
Stannis are still among the books living
for now as well Shireen Baratheon
there's no doubt that Stannis Baratheon
is a cold man in the books and on the
show as his thirst for power comes at
the expense of his affection for his
wife and daughter but the show version
of Stannis was so much worse than it had
to be in season five the red witch
Melisandre convinced Stannis and his
wife Solis to allow her to sacrifice
Shireen to the Lord of Light so he might
bless Stannis's army and lead them to
victory against the Bolton's instead
half of Stannis's army deserted him
solis hunger south and Ramsay Bolton
easily wiped out the remaining soldiers
in battle all while poor Shireen became
a pile of dust on a pyre for readers the
sacrifice scene was probably a shock
since Stannis didn't take Shireen with
him to confront Ramsay and Martin's
version in fact Shireen solis and
Melisandre were all left behind at
Castle black when his army marched with
instructions that the princess should be
left in charge if he fell as far as we
know Shireen still kicking it in a
castle even if a greyscale scars
frighten the wildlings according to the
Game of Thrones show run as though
Shireen's fiery death was one of the
three secrets that Martin revealed to
them about the future of his books so
even if living through Sherman's demise
once was enough it might happen again on
paper soon enough Alliser thorne at the
end of season five Alliser thorne
managed to organize a successful mutiny
against Jon Snow and murdered him to
claim the title of Lord Commander his
reign was sure however after Melisandre
resurrected Jon and the wildlings
captured the mutineers Jon executed
Alistar for his portrayal in the books
Alyce's still intensely dislikes Jon but
he's wisely avoiding giving Jon any
excuse to execute him I never once
disobeyed an order loyalty is the
foundation on which the Nights Watch is
built in fact Thorne was still away from
the wall when the mutineers killed
so he had no part in their treachery if
John does get resurrected in the books
then he'll no doubt execute the
mutineers but Alliser thorne won't be on
the gallows with them if I had to do it
all over knowing where at end oh I pray
and make the right choice again Tommen
Baratheon at the end of season six King
Tommen gave new meaning to the name of
his homestead King's Landing after his
wife Margaery and the entire crowd at
the Sept of Baelor were blown up by his
mother Cersei he left from his window at
the Red Keep and fell to his death well
there was a tragic end for the young
king on the show he's still alive and
seated firmly on the Iron Throne in the
books for now at least the book version
of Tommen is several years younger than
he is on the television series and his
primary hobbies are signing anything the
small council puts before him and the
playing with the kittens Margaery gave
him speaking of his lady wife she's also
still alive in the story and while the
two are married in the books they most
definitely have not consummated their
marriage bed as of a Dance with Dragons
Tommen's future rule was looking bright
with his uncle Kevin his hand and Regent
but Varys nipped that in the bud when he
murdered Kevin and pycelle considering
that the prophecy about Circe's children
dying in shrouds of gold still looms
large for all the Lannisters summons
death has probably imminent on paper as
well masala Baratheon unlike most of the
Lannisters Marcella was actually a sweet
and courteous princess who was
flourishing in Dorne and was quite
obviously in love with Prince trystane
Martell in season six though masala
became one of the victims of ilaria
sands and her daughters in her thirst
for revenge over Oberyn Martell death
olaria gave marsala a poisoned kiss that
later took her life in her uncle /
father Jaime's arms in the books however
Marcella is alive in Dorne
albeit gravely injured Cersei sends one
of the Kingsguard to bring her back to
King's Landing but Prince Doran's
daughter
Arianne abducted her in an attempt to
have her crowned an opposition of Tommen
in a confrontation with dorrance
Guardsmen one of Aryans accomplices
tries to murder masala to force a war
with the Lannisters but instead of
killing her his sword a maimed or by
cutting off her ear and leaving a nasty
scar on her face as of a dance with
dragons
Myrcella was travelling back to King's
Landing accompanied by numerous and he
will be taking a seat
small council Rickon stark on the show
@rickeon stark joined his oldest brother
Robin death when he was killed by Ramsay
Bolton to kick off the Battle of the
bastards he'd taken refuge with the
umbers but that house betrayed him by
pledging fealty and turning him over to
the Bolton's poor wreck on in the books
some Afrikaans story remains the same
OSHA took him and shaggy-dog and they
split from brands group in order to keep
the stark siblings safe last we heard of
him and have danced with dragons he'd
fled across the bay of seals where sir
Davos Seaworth was set to go retrieve
him Hodor
hold the door even though Hodor was
giving a devastating backstory and final
moment in season six the gentle giants
are still alive and well in the books in
a dance with dragons brand Meera
Jojen Hodor and summer reached the cave
of the three-eyed Raven well though they
were attacked by whites just as they
arrived everyone survived the encounter
and the brand hasn't encountered the
night King in any of his green dreams
yet if that doesn't mean Hodor will make
it through a song of ice and fire and
scavs though according to george RR
martin while the meaning of his name
will be the same in the books the way
it's origin is revealed will be
different naming martin that probably
means it would just be as heartbreaking
though Lancel Lannister
cousin Lancel future on the show went up
in smoke when he was killed in the
season six finale after being dispatched
by the high Sparrow to find Cersei
Lancel spotted one of Coburn's child
spies and followed him into the
labyrinth of passages below the Sept of
Baelor there the child shanked him and
left him to watch as a puddle of wild
fire ignited to burn him and the whole
Sept of Baelor in the books
Lancel was gravely injured in the Battle
of the Blackwater leaving him a frail
and pious man after his recovery he
joins the faith militant as a member of
the warrior Sons an order of knights
sworn to serve the High Septon and when
he last appeared in the books it was to
serve as an escort for Cersei during a
walk of atonement and a dance of dragons
so whether he'll still be punished by
way of wildfire remains to be seen which
also leaves the fates of the high
Sparrow Margaery and so Loras in
question for now as well Walder Frey
while fans of the show had to wait
several years for it Lord Walder Frey
finally got his comeuppance for the
events of the red wedding when he
killed by AI astark in the season six
finale she murdered his sons Lothar and
black Walder before baking them into a
pie and serving it to their father while
disguised as a serving wench
after she revealed herself and killed
him I had took his face and posed as
Lord Walder in order to organize a feast
for the remaining Frey kinsmen where she
murdered them all with pictures of
poisoned wine like the fine vintage that
ended the phrase the scenes were
delicious when to gain fame as
satisfying as all that was though Lord
Walder is still hale and hearty in the
books as of a dance with dragons the
prickly and treacherous octogenarian was
recently wed to another young a new wife
somehow we have to believe winter is
coming for him in the books to Olenna
Tyrell the queen of thorns Olenna Tyrell
received a relatively gentle death by
game of thrones standards in season
seven when she took the painless poison
offered to her by Jaime Lannister
after his army sacked Highgarden
displaying a trademark sharp tongue the
Tyrell matriarch opted to take the
poison before revealing to Jaime that
she was the one responsible for the
murder of his son Joffrey like her
on-screen counterparts the book version
of Elena has taken leave of King's
Landing returning to Highgarden the day
after Marjorie's wedding to Tommen she
hasn't been seen in the book since a
feast for crows so it's unknown if a
Leonard later returned to the capital
after her granddaughter was arrested by
the high Sparrow for her sake we hope
not Benjen stark uncle Benjen didn't
have a whole lot to do on Game of
Thrones
despite lasting for seven seasons he was
mostly just portrayed as a benevolent
uncle who rode in to rescue his nephews
from certain doom beyond the wall and
after he was toppled by the knight
king's army in season seven he's
probably not coming back for another
rescue mission anytime soon in the books
we never actually get a real
confirmation a benjin was a mysterious
undead Coldhands but all the clues
pointed up being the case he popped up
to save Sam and Gilly from the whites as
they fled south from Craster's keep
and he also killed the night watch his
mutineers that attacked the Lord
Commander moment so while he still can't
get past the wall because of magical
spells he's probably still lurking out
there in the woods for the next time the
three-eyed Raven needs his help
Littlefinger in the season 7 finale of
Game of Thrones
Littlefinger's scheming finally caught
up to him when Sansa decided she'd had
enough of his meddling with the help of
a nympho bomb from bran and the slicing
skills of aya Sansa managed to catch
Littlefinger in his own web of lies and
had him executed for treason and murder
in the books however Littlefinger is
still trying to pull a fast one on
people for personal reasons over in the
Eyrie following his murder of Lysa Arryn
Littlefinger's latest plot is to marry
Sansa off with Robins cousin so that she
can ascend the throne when Robin
eventually succumbs to his chronic
illnesses a sample chapter from the
winds of winter indicates that Sansa
will have mixed feelings about this
arrangement simultaneously working to
protect Robin while seducing his cousin
and since the woods which prophesize at
sunset with slay a savage giant which
sounds like the sigil of house Baelish
he might not make it much longer there
either tradition worth it'll be delayed
Viserion one of the most shocking
moments of season 7 came when Jon Snow's
brigade of zombie captors had to be
rescued from a sea of white walkers by
Daenerys and her dragons in the midst of
the rescue the night king took aim at
Viserion and managed to slay the dragon
before resurrecting him as a new and
dead mounted that he could take through
the wall in the books Vissarion and his
siblings are safe for now one of the
Martel's tried to capture one of the
dragons but failed miserably and when we
last saw Vissarion in a dance with
dragons he was happily roasting and
eating the plague filled corpses that
the yunkish army were flinging into
marine Yama the rest of the undead as if
those things weren't enough to prove the
Game of Thrones show runners have an
even heavier hand than george RR martin
some of the other characters he author
is yet to kill off include Barristan
Selmy Doran Martell Brynden the
blackfish Tully Randall and Dickon Tully
lady Walda Bolton the sand snakes
Thoros of Myr and the 1/1 just to name a
few in other words if he thought george
RR martin was savage he's clearly got
nothing on the TV show's writers
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love tea
you
[Applause]